hello and welcome to honest trailer
commentaries for Doctor Who
classic edition I'm Spencer Shay Gilbert
I'm here with the unluckiest man in the
world
Danny Merle who drew the short straw and
had to do all the classic stuff this is
the show where we talk about the show
you hopefully just watch on his trailers
for our massive undertaking for both
Doctor Who's modern and classic this
isn't regards the classic one not the
modern one that this video
do we have deleted scenes we're gonna
you know that's right no no it's all in
we're pretty lean and mean on this one
yeah yeah yeah this was interesting
let's do a little background sure before
we knew what we were getting into we
were like how should we split this up
and I am I I'd like to imagine you
volunteered but I could just be
remembering that to make myself feel
better that you volunteered to do the
classic stuff I hear was I think the
question and in front of us was this we
had we at Laura who donated to our women
in film event had specified that she
would like us to do the run of this the
span of the series and I know that we
had discussed do we do one big trailer
yeah
or do we bisect it we do classic and
modern and we talked to a few people and
everyone said classic stuff is so
different and even huge Doctor Who fans
a lot of them haven't seen all of the
classic stuff oh yeah and so it sounded
like they were very I mean there are
Doctor Who fans who only or not only but
really prefer the classic stuff but
they're a minority yes
it's mostly when you say doctor who you
think from mid aughts onward so I think
you're right I think we looked at the
number of episodes of the new modern
series and then we decided there's no
way for anyone to watch all of the
classic stuff so I we talked to Riley
who is on our was our who expert and
choose amazing and was our font of
knowledge and information and I think
she gave us some good episodes and then
I went online and just like looked at
some and like you know give you a
viewers guide to classic right some some
episodes to look at I think there's
about 200 in total give or take mmm and
I think that we looked at it and said
like well it makes the most sense
to split it up so that I had a roughly
equivalent amount of stuff to watch as
you we thought as you guys did this is a
terrible idea
that was not the way to go it was it was
very at times challenging listener with
the positive yes what did you find
charming what did you enjoy about
classic who having not seen modern who
yes I have not seen any modern who and
you guys didn't have time to see the
classic who so there was not much
intersection between our work on this
you know I found that in retrospect I
enjoyed it more than I did when I was in
it hmm it does feel very dated and I
think that the difference between the
classic stuff and from what I've seen of
the modern stuff is the modern who the
story every up the story of every
episode is forty some odd minutes hmm
and what the classic stuff I think there
I was not always so much on we have to
tell a compelling story as we have to
fill 20 to 30 minutes a week of
programming uh-huh so I found that a lot
of BBC budgets which especially back
then it was like yeah a fraction of a
penny of your tax dollars at work yeah I
felt that a lot of the classic stuff
that I watched had compelling elements
but that they were drawn out over way
too many episodes and so there was a lot
of narrative dead ends and a lot of time
filler and and it became difficult at
times to get through because there were
long stretches where nothing much seemed
to be happy you look like you're staring
into the void there for a while it got
difficult so I think I think looking
back and in retrospect looking at the
experience in total I feel like I
enjoyed the bulk of it more than I did
the individual experience of getting
through all of it I found that I found I
do see now how people have their
favorite doctors because you know
William Hartnell is different factor out
and is different from Jon Pertwee he's
different topic like they all have very
distinct personalities and I liked parts
of different them part different parts
of them toward the end it got rougher
and and if in all honesty I probably
watched the least of the seventh and
eighth doctor's or the sixth seventh the
eighth one was just the one movie I
I lose track but after you know the post
Tom Baker was probably what I watched
the least of because you know as you go
through though even the Doctor Who
classic forums and stuff finding like
these are the classic episodes like if
there's ever an episode the people said
this is a must watch yeah I watched it
yeah and then I would also watch the
worst I was I would find which ones
people thought were the worst because I
wanted to get both I wanted to get us a
flavor of everything well let me tell
you someone who started you know part of
the way into modern whoo that was my
assigned portion yeah you don't need to
watch the classic stuff at all to
appreciate it like I got what was
happening after half a season and listen
if we if we if we had decided on our own
what how we were gonna do Doctor Who I
think we would have probably said we'll
start with the new with the 2005 and on
but we had an obligation we had we had
committed to do something but not let
Laura or women and film down yes there
we go and just so you know that I do
know my doctors I know that Tom Baker's
fourth yes and Peter Davidson's fifth
Colin Baker is six Pete Davidson it's
not that Dave doesn't know not not Pete
Davidson looks like an alien and then
Colin Baker and then Sylvester McCoy and
then you have the Fox TV movie which is
the one off doctor with Alan Rickman
Eric Roberts clothes almost a doctor
anyways let's take before we start I
feeling a little naked here Oh oh my oh
here we go
cool cool cool Harry Potter scarf you
got there boy I just launched a thousand
comments let's watch Doctor Who Doctor
Who classy
you know thank you
you know his name I'm the doctor and you
know his face says and you know his
mission always the truth my truth in
this time this you're not me not Kenan
then you probably don't know any of
those things
now we live over 30 years of classic
sci-fi television that will determine
once and for all if you're a fan of
Doctor Who or a Doctor Who fan yeah
pause I thought that's all the Doctor
Who fans around the office it's like
even like yeah I love dr. he was like oh
you've seen the classic stuff now no no
no I've not seen that now like oh okay
okay yeah I would often go to like some
of the people in the office they're just
like oh I love Doctor Who I'm like can
you help me out cuz I'm trying to figure
out something around and it's like oh I
know I don't know yeah I guess it's like
people who there's Star Trek fans who
haven't seen you know the first series
sure that's that's fine you can still be
a Star Trek fan people have their
different little fandoms and the
distinction of making here when I say
this in terms of you're a fan of Doctor
Who or a Doctor Who fan I feel like if
you have seen every episode of the old
series yeah you are a doctor hufo yeah I
mean not to get keep but I think no one
can take it away from you that if you've
seen all the classics if you put in the
time and effort yeah that does not
diminish the fandom of someone who has
not but I think that's the distinctive
just like hey I'm a fan of Doctor Who
I've seen a lot of that's great but if
you've seen all of it like you are a
Doctor Who fan
it's a merit badge it's a it's an
endurance test it's like getting into
Hall H it's like one of those nerd rites
of passage yes
whew attempt it's nerd Everest it's up
there it's seeing every classic doctor
really hot in this room because you have
to you have to really seek out what
we'll talk about that later it's not
easy to watch it's not easy to watch
keep going classic Doctor Who
I like the themes lead the doctor a Time
Lord from the planet Gallifrey who
travels through space time in a machine
called the TARDIS
and that's already too weird for you tap
out now because it's about to get a
whole lot weirder on the planets of the
cheat of people in Cana Vaz
sure that is three days of adventure as
the show or I mean the doctor keeps
things fresh by regenerating into new
bodies every few years like the crabby
old man doctor who's your favorite
haircut child lot doctor cause that's a
good question um you know I again I have
not seen the totality of everything but
I feel like I saw enough of all of them
to get a good flavor of them and it
actually kind of I felt the most kind of
drawn to because they were sort of 70s
cheesy fun I liked the Jon Pertwee
episodes a lot I don't know if he was my
favorite but I like that they it's kind
of the swinging bachelor by sea and the
snake Tet Kung Fu doctor I think that
Vesuvian kung fu Venezia Jiu Jitsu I
think I [ __ ] Patrick Troughton who you
just saw had a very I think from what
I've seen his take on the doctor was the
one that has still sort of trickled down
to what is happening now Tom Baker I
think had a lot of the best story behind
him as far as like resources and it was
sort of in its heyday I think that's one
had its most watched episodes right was
during his run and then post that I
thought it tried to find its voice for a
minute and never really succeeded and it
was weird but it's kind of like the show
for a while it seems to sort of just be
like coasting on being Doctor Who and
then the movies a Fox movie and then
right yeah good for the UK for you know
they have their hits and they're just
gonna ride them until the wheels fall
off just like Doctor Who like we'll just
keep making it forever James Bond we got
a good character going here we're gonna
ditch this yeah I went from what 63 to
89 I think then they tried to bump it up
again in 96 they didn't work and then
nine years later here we here we go
again yeah and we're still going never
surrender never surrender
alright let's see the rest headed
kung-fu Austin Powers doctor
this is what most people think okay nice
I didn't have a lot of time to get into
k9 because canines got I think its own
spin-off k9 it definitely has a song
which was one of the many things I've
ever heard canine company which gets a
little bit of a name drop at the end of
this k9 was one of the Doctor Who
characters that I'm sure people ups up
and modern top something modern here and
there and for classic Who fans is a very
big part of the show that doesn't really
get much in this trailer and that's just
simply because again the breadth and
scope of this thing you really got it
there were some things that I could not
goes deep into as I wanted to important
those was k9 yeah so k9 I'm sure for
classic fans they would have wanted this
trailer to go very deep into k9 and the
fact that it's a noisy machine that
never works I just like the TARDIS
exactly just like the start there came a
point where I just had to say like I've
got to get through this because it had
been months and months mm-hmm and many
many pages of notes and it had to
sometime we have to put pen to page yes
and get this baby out so I apologized to
canine fans it wasn't quite enough all
right keep going
biz doctor how about Jenny baby don't
forget to brush it he seems nice doctor
he was the first person to know splendid
you know guys just even or the doctor
doctor no bra the almost out of gas
coasting on goodwill doctors like they
get free money from the government
yeah thank you let's go the TV movie one
off George Lazenby doctor
[Music]
but her witch doctor is operating the
TARDIS one thing remains constant he is
either the most overrated or underrated
doctor of all time in either the most
overrated or underrated era of the show
I already got a bus hitting Doctor Who
fans to agree on who's the best doctor
is I trying to watch every episode of
Doctor Who it's pretty much impossible
so why even try and fun I found again as
someone who was looking for I gave up
very early on of this I was like what
are some consensus episodes that are
like the best of the show or conversely
what are some consensus episodes that
are the worst of the show I found very
clear that that was not going to happen
no because everyone every different era
of who fandom has episodes that are the
best yeah but the other side that fandom
will tell you why those episodes are
overrated and are actually not that good
and why these other episodes are the
best but then that other side will tell
you why those episodes are terrible oh
you should watch straight on through
modern you can find the most vitriolic
hateful things written about each doctor
and each companion followed by you know
why they're without a doubt the absolute
best thing to ever happen yeah Doctor
Who there's been so because it's been
going for so many decades there's been
time for groundswell of support and
backlash and backlash to the backlash
and backlash that backlash yeah it's
just swinging back and forth and this
never-ending a time void yeah it got to
the point where I just had to go to like
five different sites and literally write
like in a spreadsheet like which
episodes were recommended here and then
talked to Riley and get some
recommendations there and then sometimes
just go through and look at just like
random ones that I thought were you know
this seems useful or you know it's like
well I say that you know I go through
and look at clips and be like okay where
did this clip come from looking from
that episode okay I'm gonna watch that
one it was a very I'm sure that they're
classic fans they're like well you could
never really comment on the series
unless you've seen the whole thing I
would have liked to in a world where
there was unlimited time I would have
loved I would have definitely was that
and what done that I would have done
that but you know I I hope that fans
will think that well we'll find this
representative of the show yeah that's
really what we were that's our one hope
yeah I'll say I'm sure it won't keep
going during his companion's take on
some of the most iconic villains
all time like the Daleks they don't get
much better sighs no that's pretty much
my anymore Rose do get back disciple
time the bastard the other watching
whatever villains and some bills that it
sounds like they're just making up on
the spot that Damon was from the planet
demos watch the Donovan story serialized
across three four six or even ten
episodes jam-packed with enough plot to
fill maybe two
yeah I think modern who kind of
alleviates this although there are two
part episode a lot but for the most part
they're season-long arcs so in a
40-something minute episode you'll have
30 minutes dedicated to the story of the
week and ten minutes will be like
furthering something that will pay off
in the finale sure in this case you have
a storyline like the Dalek invasion of
Earth which I believe was six or eight
parts mm-hmm which has a great story
which is that they land in the UK they
always I land in London but it's in the
future and the Daleks have invaded and
they've taken over the planet a great
story and and this is a first doctor
story and it ends in a really compelling
way because he leaves his companion
Susan his granddaughter there strands
her but because he thinks that she's
going to be happy there
it ends great and it's a great setup but
in the middle there's a lot of episodes
where like the whole episode is
literally just they get captured and
they get uncaptured and that's it and
then the next and so there's very little
in the it's just a lot of wheel spinning
it seems like so I that was my biggest
hurdle with this was it wasn't that I
didn't like the source material or the
the performances it was that it moved
often at a very glacial patient wait a
very hard by the way to binge and and
get through a bunch of it quickly
well that's Riley but I wonder what the
the release schedule was like for this
classic stuff because weekly weekly yeah
okay every week and they so they just
had to fill a lot of time a lot of times
it seemed like they just sort of needed
to fill that space yeah I mean it almost
feels like the days of like radio plays
of just like this week the doctor is in
the captivity of the dollar it is very
serializing it's very serialized and I'm
sure that part of that is at that time
that was just how things were done but I
think with a modern sensibility and I
think partly when you have a person like
myself who is looking at a hundred and
seventy five more to watch you get
caught in the middle and it just seems
like a bit of a bit sluggish yeah at
times yeah well it's a labor of love or
at least a labor keep going come on
Whovian
even you have to admit the show is very
deliberate newly drawn out witness the
paradox that is classic Doctor Who a
show that's both timeless and completely
out of date what you needed our
colleague real as it seems to predict
future phenomena like The Matrix gasa
must have a solid link with the matrix
the booth - crazy many things
along the Stephen King I should have to
go to the doctor and be movie according
to classical aerodynamics is impossible
for a bumblebee to fly now also being
completely inappropriate for modern
times I'm saying I could swim but you're
trying to use I feel no pain okay we're
all Chinese got some scrapings of
Shanghai and one midgets and there's the
episode the challenge of Wing Chang I
have a stand we all look the same
wow that is one of those episodes that
is according to some who fans the
pinnacle of Doctor Who of all time the
best story ever told on Doctor Who and
then you go another and they're like
that's not that good right
it is 100% full of issues sure again it
that that is kind of the crux of like
classic sci-fi storytelling and good
lord could this be any more out of date
yeah I think they they forget a lot of
the time at least in modern that I guess
he's kind of all-knowing but at the same
time it seems like they forget that the
doctor is an alien a lot of the time
because he's always cracking like earth
jokes and has earth prejudices or at
least knows about earth biases and stuff
to the point where he's like responding
to the minutiae of oh well she's a
Scottish girl and you know how Scottish
girls are you've been across the entire
universe why do you know so much about
the UK in the late 2000 and it's yeah I
guess he just knows a lot he's there all
the time yeah I mean there's one word
like there well I I wondered though
because there's like the most the most I
think the most viewed episode of all
times was an episode called city of
death but it takes place in Paris and
doctor the doctor I almost did it yeah
the doctor says oh this is the best
place to vacation in the galaxy it's
like wow like if you're watching the UK
in the doctors talk about how France is
the best place ever stuck for like kids
who wanted to explore the galaxy like oh
I guess I'll go across the channel and
like that's really the best hope I have
yeah yeah the rest of it sucks yeah and
then they traveled back in time to find
Leonardo da Vinci because there was an
alien who had split himself across time
was present in multiple different oh
it's a great sure ever historical figure
you will have cross paths with the
doctors Julian Glover and he took off a
mask like my teacher was an alien then
he had like a green face underneath yeah
well no he's friends with da Vinci and
he was keeping him captive if I recall
correctly this is pretty crazy episode
fun stories not at one episode is this
story series yes excuse me oh so if you
like TV shows that you can easily kick
back and watch on Netflix then
definitely don't start watching Doctor
Who as this completionist nightmare will
send you scrambling to find episodes of
the BBC erased decades ago by hunting
down dozens of DVD boxsets
animated recreations and audio plays
playing breakdancer magically turns up
like those episodes from Africa pause
but those animated recreations are so
strange that is that's one of the like
the official like it's a quick box like
that's one of like the official ones
there's other ones that that fan and
have fans have done that are animated
there's some that are there was one that
I was watching I'm just kind of watching
through cuz what happened we is
literally they were erased like there
was a time when the BBC was like okay we
aired it we can just erase it now and so
all that survives is audio sometimes
you'll watch an episode and it's just
stills I was watching one it was just
like oh yeah I have no video duction
stills or just like video stills from
previous episodes it's sort of
illustrate what characters are talking
yeah and then like I say the radio plays
there's a bunch of novelizations
recreations restate it it's it's truly
insane to try to piece together every
single yeah a story from every single
doctor and particularly the first doctor
in the second doctor so many of them are
just going out forever that's incredible
it's vanished
it's almost it boggles the mind to think
of in this day and age of like a
television show could completely
disappear but yeah it'll probably happen
more and more when we switch over to
streaming when people just like yeah we
pulled it from the service yeah we don't
have a backup or maybe it's locked away
somewhere and some vault but I mean
they're they're films that have largely
you know films that didn't make the jump
from VHS to DVD or from DVD to blu-ray
or streaming you know there are movies
that oh I'd like to watch that movie you
can't find it yeah it was it was never
produced
for whatever reason in different formats
but not erase completely is there some
you know annex of the the London of the
tube or something with like someone
dropped a parcel full of Doctor Who
episode we talked about there was this
there there was a storeroom and I
believe it was Nigeria sure a few years
ago where they found yeah like 13
episodes it was like a satellite
operation from the BBC that someone had
made a taped backup of Doctor Who 50
years ago and they just miraculously
found these like 10 episodes that people
had thought were gone forever so there's
always the chance search every former
colony of the British Empire I will find
the Doctor Who missing episode just
promise you they have scoured the globe
to try to find these things thank you if
you do somehow make it through all 26
series specials and TV movies then
answer me this why do Doctor Who fans
get so angry every time people call him
Doctor Who I'm the doctor I keep telling
you that when that's what the show
called him for 18 years you don't
understand story easily defeated Daleks
[Music]
my favorite Oh dad's yeah I think part
of it was that these were not stuff
people know so they just did it whatever
speed was safe for them convoluted plots
you think for one moment that I there's
the mole the topsail doubt you the more
you must convince or Florida for all
your taxes nerd advisees it'll be like
really in the Train there's no
compartment containing three dots
[Music]
[Applause]
I watched catering company
just stop Inspector Spacetime community
record sir
okay Inspector Spacetime with this solo
the sonic screwdriver that's basically
just a fancy door opener right yeah
that's what I thought about half of what
he uses it for is uh it's almost doesn't
work on this lock or or it works on the
lock if they depend on the plot needs
yeah yeah
so yeah that's classic Doctor Who you
did it man I did it I I do feel I
understand why if you grew up with it
disturbing you you would be so it would
be very endearing - sure it is very
daunting yeah and then I'm not gonna lie
a little difficult to jump into cold but
I I feel like it's I get it I get it I
certainly get it and and I do think i
think i think most more insulting to
fail not like i don't like it no i
removed from it looking back on it yeah
i it is much more endearing than it was
while I was watching it I think I can
see why so many people that grew up with
it looking back on it remember the kind
of fun and quirky stuff about it and the
stuff they enjoyed and you know it does
get philosophical and they're you know
it's very profound in different moments
and so I understand particularly with
the value of hindsight how you know week
to week maybe it could be a little
difficult to get through but looking
back on it yeah I I see why people enjoy
it okay like just even then watching the
honest trailer and then watching a few
episodes over your shoulder it's like
there's some retro charm to it it is
yeah especially if you just like like
English culture in the 60s and 70s it's
it's just fun to look at it's like
watching an old Beatles movie it's very
mod and I also it was fun
you know while it may not have been
ideal for a fan of the show for this to
be the way for a newcomer to experience
it it was fun just sort of fast-forward
a little bit in the sense of like you
know I'm not watching all seven years of
the 60s at once so you know I'm going
from 63 sometimes to like 65 to 67 - 68
and then jump to like 70 and like you
can follow it through the decades and
even just watching the the credits
evolved and the the tone of it like it
starts off as a sort of 60s horror
sci-fi and then it goes into kind of
with the 70s you get that kind of James
Bond Roger Moore era velvet suits you
know action type show you can see where
pop culture was and then you get into
the like the mid to late 80s and it's
that sort of gothic horror you know the
the kind of stuff that you were seeing
with like Twilight Zone the series at
that time and you're like all of these
sort of like mid 80s to late eighties
shows that were like capitalizing I'm
like the horror genre and it's kind of
fun to track the show that's cool yeah
edgy definitely don't you at that in the
new one it's because what happened to
culture between 2005 and today like yeah
not much yeah so thank you for your
service Stan yes it was I hope the
people liked the trailer I hope they
liked it too I hope that they liked the
other one as well which we will be doing
a commentary for shortly after this one
yes man are you actually checked out the
newest episode of the new one so did it
did will you be moving forward with who
I'm I don't know I don't I I honestly
don't know it's it's I again like I
totally get the charm of it but I'm not
entirely sure that it's for me well I
appreciate your honesty yeah and I
appreciate your watching so thank you
for giving us a chance please be kind
just like the doctor would some of the
doctors and check back right now as a
video before after this one for the
Australian commentary for Doctor Who
modern see you later thanks
you
[Music]